élément est à il ya vu le jour en 2016
elle fait partie du millas laboratoire
pensé par ailleurs choix bendjo qui fait
rayonner l'intelligence artificielle la
silicon valley da déjà sorti ciel à
montréal et aujourd'hui c'est la silicon
valley qui vient mettre le grappin sur
cette entreprise phare elle qui avait
obtenu plusieurs centaines de millions
de dollars de financement vesna une
compagnie californienne de dix mille
employés rachète la montréalaise et ses
quelque 300 employés pour un montant non
divulgué
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui montréal est
clairement sur la mappemonde
international devenu le un pôle de
talent en intelligence artificielle
évidence faut être très vigilant si
c'est effectivement devenir autre
guillemets siphonner nos talents et pour
pouvoir effectivement l'amener à
l'extérieur du québec j'aurais y aura
des grandes questions à se poser
québec avait prévu d'investir jusqu'à 25
millions de dollars américains le
ministre de l'économie se dit déçu que
l'entreprise n'ait pas pu percer tout
seul
seulement la moitié étaient des bourses
et une banque 12.5 millions us qui va
être qu'ils vont être payés total 1 par
l'opération donc le groupe de joueurs
vainqueurs depuis un an
de son côté la caisse de dépôt et
placement a aussi un investissement
évalué entre 30 et 50 millions de
dollars et se réjouit de cet achat saw
vi now s'est engagé à faire de montréal
le pôle canadien de l'intelligence
artificielle en maintenant la main
d'oeuvre ici et en faisant venir 200 de
ses employés lmt a et restera donc
montréalaise mais tous les savoirs et
l'expertisé qu'elle a développée
deviendront l'année prochaine propriété
californienne
quant à yushu avenger lui il deviendra
conseiller stratégique pour sauver saab
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal